dianna of a mascara warrior princess
demigod heroine much of wonder woman's
illustrious legacy in comics has had her
act not just the Saviour to the little
man but also as arbiter and conscience
for her fellow heroes when they should
fall short of the task at hand it's no
overstatement to describe Wonder Woman
as an ultimate avatar of justice and
peace motivated by a pure desire to
right wrongs and help literally anyone
in need so surely she'd be worthy enough
to lift Thor's hammer mjolnir right heck
a surface level comparison between Thor
and Wonder Woman suggests that the
amazonian may actually be more worthy to
wield to the hammer than the god of
thunder for one Thor's trigger finger is
ichiya than Diana's while as guardians
in general tend to be more morally great
than the Amazonians of the thermos Kyra
to setting aside the obvious corporate
barrier between the two characters it's
definitely worth asking just how well
could diana measure up to the standards
of Mjolnir
well let's take a deeper look the exact
words on Mjolnir rate whosoever home to
this hammer
if he be worthy shall possess the
powerful no greater context is really
available besides the content of comics
Callen which is slippery on its best day
objectively bad people have used me only
in the past low-key for example though
he had helped from a spell that allowed
him to circumvent the rules and then
there was the time that the mad thinkers
awesome Android was permitted to wield
Mjolnir while inherently unqualified to
use the hammer on fair and square terms
the Android used his ability to copy
others qualities and made himself worthy
he didn't copy Thor's powers though
instead mimicking his an aged character
though he could only do this for an hour
at a time but also this still suggests
the mystical hammer is flexible to
technicalities it's also clear that the
rules of the hammer can be changed based
on individual circumstances and that its
definition of worthiness isn't strictly
limited to whether or not a character is
lawful good or not just look at the
hammers MCU history as the man who
enchanted me only in the first place
Odin literally defined what worthiness
is to the hammer inspired largely by
Thor's misguided actions in his first
movie for of course then had to prove
his worthiness based on that set of
standards but this also means that the
Hammers rules aren't necessarily set in
stone and sure enough black many tropes
surrounding the usage of magic and
pop-culture the rules around using yon
ear legitimately adjust this vague and
loophole filled enough to permit a whole
bunch of extenuating circumstances for
example in the comic JLA slash Avengers
from back when Marvel and DC could do
crossovers like that Superman himself
was permitted to raise the hammer but
only for one fight and he was unable to
pick it up again once hostilities ceased
that's probably a fair deal turn while
there are times when Superman needs a
little boost for a good cause he
probably shouldn't be able to casually
haul such a weapon around after all he
does tend to gather in his head that
he's the
only real arbiter of truth justice and
the American Way but what does that mean
specifically for Diana and her potential
ability to lift Thor's hammer well think
of it this way no matter what Wonder
Woman is an inherently good person who
is selflessly devoted to the notion of
justice so there's no reason to believe
she wouldn't be able to lift it in times
of need and this is backed up by a comic
event - albeit a non canon one in 1996
DC and Marvel ran a short crossover
series entitled Marvel Comics vs. DC in
this story diana picks up neon here
after it appears through a wormhole
but after wasting the hammer and
appreciating the power and abuse upon
her Wonder Woman decides it actually
isn't fair to use the hammer during the
fight she's in word storm
so she relinquishes me on there and
loses the battle as a result the truth
here seems to be that Wonder Woman can
lift me on me but she's actually too
good for it and will voluntarily discard
it because the abilities it gives her
are impermissibly powerful and that's
just about as worthy as you can get
isn't it check out one of our newest
videos right here plus even more looper
videos about your favorite superheroes
they're coming soon subscribe to our
youtube channel and hit the bell so you
don't miss a single one